my friends are following in the very  footsteps of history something beyond  the power of words to describe human  beings simply aren't built to function  at the cruising altitude of a 747 our  bodies will be literally dying Everest  is another beast all together back  Hanson  what do you do when you're not climbing  duck I deliver the men first Batman on  Everest okay sit down  climate eyes how's the widow it's good  goose was with me one day you mean that  little Sarah and we go climbing together  today's a day huh  it hurts it's dangerous why I have kids  they see a regular guy can follow  impossible dreams maybe they'll do the  same  behind  Sue's hair color yeah  getting down together now let's go